this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
today's episode he's going to be
checking out the arsenal from the beta
of battlefield 2042 if you want to see
more of jonathan's take on the
battlefield franchise make sure to
subscribe as we've got videos in
battlefield 1 4 5 and bad company 2 as
well and if there are any other games
guns and mechanics you guys want to see
nothing breakdown let us know in the
comment section below and of course if
you'd like to help out the royal
armouries museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
so only 20 years into
the future
we're not going to see any ray guns what
we might see in fact we will see at
least in some
security services if not armed forces
is the sig mcx or a derivative
all
is what i'm holding here is
the bog standard vertus in 5.56 and
there are different calibers available
here it is labeled multi-caliber 300
blackout for example
but what we're seeing here is a
virtual depiction of
the mcx spear
which is actually a different weapon
it's a derivative part of the same
family broadly speaking as the
conventional mcx and the virtus the
rattler all of those but this thing is
substantially redesigned so you can't
look at this and critique the model we
see in the game because this is very
likely quite accurate to the real mcx
spear which was created for the
us government's next generation squad
weapon program i think we've mentioned
before on the series
with several different entrants trying
to really push the envelope of small
arms technology in particular in terms
of
velocity what the us government special
specified was a 6.8
caliber diameter projectile traveling at
something in the order of 3000 feet per
second which is very high velocity for a
large bullet like that relatively large
bullet with the idea of defeating
potential enemy body armor like serious
business ceramic
um level four equivalent body armor that
will stop conventional rifle rounds so
that's what we're seeing here this is a
fictional future where clearly somebody
has adopted this
however and bearing in mind we don't
have an mcx spear and we may never have
one um there's something not quite right
about the model right off the bat here
so i'm looking at this canted to the
side looking into the chamber for a
reload the rail on the top
is not right that should be picatinny uh
mill standard 1913 what's now a nato
standard with regularly
narrowly spaced grooves we're used to
seeing that you know we know that what
that rail is we don't know what it's
called
here the grooves are far too widely
spaced they've dropped the ball there in
the modelling
if we're going to be nerdy about it and
of course we are it's what we're here
for
what we see here with a a quick select
wheel type arrangement to allow you to
swap attachments on the fly kind of
thing
there's no reason why that would be the
case
it's just as easy if not easier to
correctly attach something where you
have lots of small
spaces rather than
limited amounts of spaces um you could
argue that back and forth
maybe that was their logic i don't think
it holds up
more interesting than that little nerdy
detail is this whole idea of swapping
accessories as you run around the
battlefield now um quick change barrels
have been a thing for a long time um
they would be changed in the field on
certain machine guns with a certain
round count to ensure that the barrel
didn't get too hot so that's a that's a
thing so sound suppressors you would
potentially
uh quick detach
and take off if
you know you're compromised and you need
to just
you don't need them anymore you might
take them off probably wouldn't
there isn't much advantage to doing so
taking sites on and off as we see you
can do here modern sites will will
do have um what they call return to xero
so you can in theory take them off
put them on again
that's really intended for sort of
between missions
you you don't you don't be doing that in
the middle of
certainly not in the middle of a
firefight and probably not
really while you're in the field the
closest practical
version of that are these hybrid
sights with magnifiers that rock in and
out of place or i've even seen them that
do quick detach so you might put your
magnifier on the gun and take it off the
gun what you wouldn't do is take this
site on and off many many accessories
don't allow you to do that this one is
not quick to attach it requires allen
keys
um
even ones that do it's just generally
not not a good idea so i can absolutely
see why they've done this as the sort of
next evolution in
game guns
but it's not
what would happen
in real life
so somehow simply by changing magazines
we are changing
calibres
um
you can't do that
you cannot simply pivot to a round with
a com with completely different
dimensions whether that's the much
bigger longer beefier 6.8 or the much
smaller squat
pistol caliber round you can't do that
you'd need
an adapter for the magazine well you
would need a different bolt to take the
whole gun apart to make these changes so
that is completely unrealistic and a
little bit of a downer for what's meant
to be a
somewhat realistic first person shooter
kind of intrigued to see what the
gameplay possibilities are that open up
from that but um a bit of a black mark
from from me there i'm afraid
right um a bit of a
familiar sight for those of you who've
been watching along at home we've got
the
knights armament um kac
assault light assault machine gun it's
quite distinctive with that um almost
girder profile receiver
i think perhaps more interestingly is
the weapons handling
whilst dangling from parachute
so when we read stories wartime stories
of paratroopers shooting
certainly being shot at but also
shooting from the parachute um not very
common typically you wouldn't have
access to your weapon as you parachute
into a
to a drop zone um certainly not in a
second world war context
but if you did happen to jump out of an
aircraft with your firearm ready to go
who knows um you're both got both hands
free so you could do something with it
but that's quite a lot of sort of fine
motor skills um
on display there
when you should really be steering
your parachute
generally you don't want to be
attracting attention whilst coming in on
a parachute because it's a lot easier
for ground forces to shoot up at you
than it is for you to shoot off a
parachute but it's a very action movie
thing to do
and more than anything else that's
really what the battlefield games are
they're like um war themed action movies
that you play
i think it's fair to say
but um as far as the how fitting the the
gun choices
yep absolutely um i'd still class this
as a future weapon although the design
has been around for a while
of course we've got to have a
futuristic-looking kalashnikov
in a game like this and in this case
it's pretty much with a couple of detail
differences the real world ak-12 well
actually we've seen the original
incarnation of the ak-12 the more
radically different looking gun
in previous battlefield games the big
chunky looking thing
without the classic safety selector
switch of the ak
things were scaled back from there and
what was originally dubbed the ak-400
series was
renamed the ak-12 effectively it's still
a modernized ak it's still very capable
so that's what we're seeing here the bus
stock on this is the original version
which looks like an m4 sliding type
that's been replaced in production with
something
more unique
and actually cooler looking i think now
it's not called the ak-12 they've
doubled the number and called it the
ak-24
what makes it an ak-24
maybe that bizarre little metal loop on
the side of the top cover which i have a
horrible feeling is for hanging charms
from we've got some funky reloads going
on as well as we're used to by now a bit
of an error which i imagine is a beta
version thing where the what was an
empty round that's flying out of the gun
visibly has cartridges in it so i'm sure
they'll fix that before release
now not really
well not really a firearm it's it's a
gun i suppose or is it does it have a
barrel
guns need to have a barrel
a grappling hook gun thing it's a bit
batman
it's a bit uh just cause but we now have
it for better or worse in a battlefield
game i think for the first time don't
remember ever having a grappling gun
mixed feelings about that i mean it
clearly opens up some great gameplay
opportunities such as we've just seen
where you go shooting up the side of a
structure and superhero land at the top
while shooting someone in the face but
needless to say that's not how actual
practitioners would use
a grappling gun if indeed they use
grappling guns in that way i mean
it has certainly been used in a sort of
hostage rescue type situation
something of that nature i mean as far
as i know a grappling gun you can shoot
it up over something give it a tug to
make sure it's wrapped around whatever
you've attached to and then climb up it
or attach to it and wrap repel down it's
pushing the boundaries of tactical kit i
think but they do exist grappling guns
the chris vector we have covered this
one before very futuristic looking gun
but is is it a future gun i don't know
i don't have a crystal ball or a time
machine
battlefield has a bit of a history just
because of having to anticipate what
real world military forces are going to
do
technology has kind of plateaued and
certainly for military forces you need a
significant advantage to adopt something
new and potentially unproven as well
it's the other thing things have to
mature over time to become become seen
as reliable to make it through trials
and the vector has the disadvantage of
being a pistol caliber weapon and so and
those things are uh niche weapons these
days they're for security forces maybe
maybe police and they cannot penetrate
body armor
nine millimeter 45
they cannot penetrate body armor so
and the big drive at the moment in
the military side of things is to combat
pier level forces with body armor and in
this sort of private military contractor
insurgent type scenario you know
everyone has got body armor it's
proliferated now so if we're playing the
crystal ball game i don't really
necessarily see that
being a battlefield weapon fascinating
design more fascinating even i think
that it is becoming such a pop culture
darling
um like the p90 did
really a military weapon the revolver
no serious military user is going to be
using revolvers for just about anything
even magnum revolvers like this
this is meant to be a taurus uh model
the the shape of the rear sight is
identical
this version has
as some modern magnum revolvers do have
an accessory rail on
the barrel flat which this is too old to
have that but it's the same size
proportions and power this is really a
target pistol i know it might seem odd
but um
the the ability to accurately control
with follow-up shots magnum pistols
is you know it's a sporting discipline
um
they're also used for for hunting in
certain situations as well
what they're not used for is attacking
enemy soldiers just to really take the
biscuit here
what we're seeing is a switch to
arm piercing handgun rails
um
those are a thing
sort of for soft body armor
what they can't do is the slightest bit
of damage to armored vehicle armor
certainly not an armored vehicle such as
we saw getting shot at there i don't
care how armor-piercing the bullet is
there is not enough propellant there is
not a fast enough burn rate
and the the bullet is not aerodynamic
enough or um
does not have the the right sectional
density
even if it's a super hard tungsten
penetrator to get anywhere through tank
armor um that's kind of why tanks have
tank guns you know i think i'm i'm quite
um accepting of balancing out realism
with cool um for me that's just a step
too far i don't really see why it i
don't think it even helps
necessarily gameplay either because for
me at least it's better to have a
dedicated anti-tank weapon that can do
meaningful damage
yeah i'm not i'm not a huge fan of that
the reload trick he's doing here is
plausible so the the unfired rounds are
heavier so the fire cases will stay in
the cylinder and it is possible to let
inertia or gravity
drop the unfired rounds into your hand
save those for a reload and then hit the
ejector rod
to eject the fired cases and what we see
here is plausible it might not work
every time but i think if you got
familiar enough with the weapon you
could probably make it happen every time
so
that's that's really that's quite an
impressive bit of um bit of work there
yeah manual shotguns are still around
because they're flexible but that's
really more of a police law enforcement
type scenario to a limited extent
applies to military forces but they will
be using they'll either be using
manually or manually operated shotguns
purely for breaching for taking down
doors that kind of thing
or they'll be using self-loading
shotguns
that they might use for both breaching
and for close quarter fighting but they
will be self-loading um you need the
advantage of semi-automatic fire and
even then they're not common um the
british army used a combat shotgun the
benelli m4
in
afghanistan and then
when the conflict drew down it set its
side and abandoned shotguns again
okay i don't know if this is another
beta version glitch but
switching ammunition for a shotgun
eminently doable it's done quite a bit
but the glitch comes in if it i hope it
is a glitch that simply by swapping
the ammunition type in the menu your gun
is magically full again i'm hoping
that's not actually a gameplay feature
so i would expect to see shotguns become
probably less common in future
and the manual shotgun really hasn't got
a place on a on a literal battlefield
right a fictional designation for what
is actually the
um sarco
uh trg
sniper rifle uh modern sniper rifle with
a
machined
lightweight alloy chassis rather than a
conventional wooden stock you know the
drill by now
and a bolt action still so we're 20
years on we're still using bolt actions
i think that's plausible i think
there'll always be a plate on always
perhaps but there will be a place as
recently as that for both guns in the
sniper roll 338 lapper magnum um very
hot cartridge right now uh literally um
as well as
uh fashionably
and will continue to be so 338 gives you
that power to reach out long distance
with armor penetrating capability but
it's also just a almost the perfect
sniper round for military purposes
for the time being at least so
i'd expect to see it and here it is
now 338 lapra magnum is a very long
range relatively flat shooting powerful
cartridge um but we see here at i think
what was it 400 and something meters
i don't think we'd see that much bullet
drop on that cartridge at that distance
um but battlefield has always kind of
artificially induced bullet drop to make
things manageable
on it on a map on the hardware of the
day
the uh likewise the rail system on the
top of the gun is standard on sniper
rifles now it's no longer a proprietary
setup
albeit the weird battlefield 9 2042 rail
the scope looks a bit weird in terms of
the reticle that's that's quite an
old-fashioned looking
um what would have once been very thin
gauge wire inside the scope and is now
generally etched onto something
um there are no
there are no graphic graduations on
there there's no
nothing else going on now i'm not great
on long-range marksmanship i haven't
seen as many scopes some of you probably
have but i'd expect some sort of
symbology in there
in a future version of a magnified
optical sight and we're not seeing it
there um in fact i would hope to see
some electro optical sighting systems on
sniper rifles and moment i haven't seen
those perhaps they're in the game
perhaps they'll be added later
thermal
guided triggers
bullet drop range estimation with lasers
all of those sort of features are
already out there and i'd expect those
to become standard and miniaturized
maybe even with little built-in drones
that fly downrange and measure the wind
for you downrange um
not seeing much 2042 about this sniper
rifle but it
i can believe it be around
reloading ammunition
now of course glock is still going to be
going strong
in 2042 absolutely no doubt about that
the fact they'll become more ubiquitous
rather than less
um how much will they change don't know
every five ten years glock really
releases a slightly different block um
this is a version of the glock 18 it's
got a very high g number which by the
way does not refer to the patent some
people insist on saying
um you don't get a different patent for
every model of gun you invent no more
than ford gets a different patent for
every model of focus that it creates
anyway sorry
so it's meant to be like a future glock
it's the same capability as the 18 so
fully automatic same as this
semi-auto full auto
selector switch on the side what i've
chosen from from the collection to show
you um because we don't have future
non-existent glocks um incidentally the
frame on this is closest to a generation
4 which the 18 doesn't exist in it only
comes in gen 3. i've chosen our earliest
18 which is a generation 2 so it doesn't
have the accessory rail on the front it
doesn't have the finger grooves or the
thumb groove on the side but modern
blocks have returned to a finger
grooveless frame anyway and it's the
oldest one we have so this will be
mid 80s it does fire in for auto
various options available so this has a
plus two base plate that gives you two
extra rounds over the normal 17
you've got the classic 33 rounder which
we have as well
and you have drum magazines
now i don't know if um
battlefield is giving you that option
but
it's one of the few cases where drum
magazine on a pistol might make some
sort of sense
just some sense
there is something there is a feature on
on this
virtual glock that does not exist on any
real ones and that's a weird addition to
the front of the frame it doesn't appear
to be a clamp on accessory rail should
have its own accessory rail anyway
i don't know what purpose that's serving
but it does make it look slightly
futuristic and may justify the um
g57 i think it was
glock has such an
after-market of components that you can
get a frame that looks like almost
anything
i've not seen one with that feature on
it though
so the current version of the carl
gustav recoilless
gun
coil this weapon
is the m4
we have an earlier version we've shown
on the channel before
so it's not a guided system it is you
know you point and shoot and then the
potential for upgrade upgrade really is
in payload that's in the munition to
make it more armor penetrative or
whatever effect you want on target
uh but also electro optical aiming
systems that make it easier to put that
thing on target
what doesn't make it easier to put the
munition the um
projectile on target is a little
electronic message that says
round fired please reload
i think the big clue there is the big
flash and bang and hopefully a tank
exploding in front of you
that's a bit of a cue to reload i don't
think you need a little message to tell
you how to do it i suspect they've
included that as a bit of fun
thanks everyone that was the guns of
battlefield 2042 which i am excited to
play although i'm not quite sure what
i'm going to get around to it as always
we have a link in the description for
donations or even membership or the
membership program for the royal
armouries museum
you can check out our social media
streams if you like
we have events going on and we have our
three sites that you can come and visit
if you're able to reach them
in any case i'll see you again next time
thanks
[Music]